nowadays due to the increasing
competition in the fashion industry
selling cosmetics has become extremely
difficult however for our protagonist
nick everything is a piece of cake
recently because of an accident he has
received a unique ability with the help
of which he can read other women's minds
he uses this ability to tap into their
thoughts and to know their likes and
dislikes in this way he is able to sell
just about anything with that being said
life was not always easy for nick to
know how it all changed let's rewind to
a few months back starting with our
protagonist's introduction nick marshall
is an executive marketing officer who
plies his trade in a large company in
shanghai he is an excellent employee who
always receives the best results for the
company however there is one slight
problem nick is a narcissist he thinks
highly of himself and also believes that
all girls like him actually nick has
always been this way right from his
childhood even as a kid he used to flirt
with older women so that he could get
money from them as nick grew older he
became a playboy and started having
one-night affairs with women he even
started calling himself god's gift to
women this guy should throw himself
straight in the trash nick was married
to a rich woman named gigi but their
relationship didn't last long because of
his extravagant lifestyle he has a teen
daughter alex but the little girl is
always cold to him as he has been absent
throughout her life
apart from this nick has several other
women in his life for instance he lives
in his house with his maids tammy who
takes care of his entire schedule also a
girl named lola who works at his
favorite coffee shop and also happens to
be his crush despite being a virtuoso
and attracting women and sleeping with
them nick is oblivious to their psyche
this is a huge disadvantage for him as
women are becoming the fastest growing
consumer group in china and since he has
no knowledge of how they feel selling
products to them has become a
challenging task nick finally realizes
that he is in trouble when his boss dan
hires a woman named darcy for the
position of the company's new creative
director nick was sure that the position
would become his but because of his lack
of knowledge on women's psyche he has
been disregarded meanwhile we get to
know that darcy is one of the best
marketing officers in the country and
has a reputation of being daunting to
men one day nick calls his ex-wife who
is on the verge of getting remarried
however instead of congratulating her he
simply asks about his daughter gigi
informs him that she will be going on a
fortnight long honeymoon with her new
husband and asks nick to take care of
their daughter alex until she comes back
despite being a terrible father nick
loves alex very much but when he learns
that she has made a new boyfriend he
becomes upset there's not enough room in
this place for two players however alex
doesn't care about his opinion as he has
never been there for her when it
mattered in the next scene it is the
first day of work for darcy she gathers
everyone and delivers an inspiring
speech promising to help the company tap
into the women's consumer market she
then hands all the employees a box of
feminine products and asks them to come
up with ideas to sell them the box
contains different products like a
waxing kit a pregnancy test lipstick
bath beads etc later at home a desperate
nick tries to brainstorm ideas on how to
sell the lipstick but he can't come up
with any just then a thought comes into
his mind in order to know a woman he has
to become a woman he then notices his
daughter's phone and plays some songs
from her playlist after this he tries
several of her products and clothes all
while drinking alcohol while he is at it
alex suddenly walks in with her
boyfriend embarrassed by the incident
alex immediately sends her boyfriend
home and confronts her father for going
through her things nick tries to explain
that he was just trying to find some
ideas but the little girl is having none
of it and goes straight to her bed even
after she is gone nick continues
brainstorming ideas for the marketing
campaign but only ends up becoming drunk
as he is wearing high heels he
accidentally slips and falls into his
bathtub which is filled with water to
make matters worse his fish bulb also
falls into the tub which electrocutes
him rendering him unconscious when he
wakes up in the hospital the next day he
finds a nurse looking after him
surprisingly he overhears her thoughts
where she is complaining about his
unhygienic lifestyle nick is startled by
the strange occurrence but he doesn't
think much of it and continues on with
his day later he heads to the park to
clear his mind however all he can hear
are the thoughts of random women one
woman is angry with her partner while
another is scared of becoming a lesbian
as she just made out with a girl all of
this terrorizes nick and he rushes to
his office but it gets even worse there
he learns that his female co-workers
think badly of him one woman calls him a
jerk while another makes fun of his
appearance with all this going around
nick tries to rush to his doctor but a
co-worker drags him to the scheduled
meeting there he cannot stop thinking
about his new disease but after a while
he uses it to read the women's thoughts
and impress darcy in the evening when
nick returns home he walks in on alex
making out with her boyfriend like any
other father he gets angry and orders
the boy to leave but this just enrages
alex and she says terrible things about
her dad and her mind after alex leaves
next starts drinking heavily as he is
fed up with women talking bad about him
he goes outside with the same fish bulb
and electrocutes himself thinking that
it will bring him back to normalcy but
the plan fails terribly the following
morning nick wakes up to find his maid
cleaning the house surprisingly she is
the only person who doesn't have bad
thoughts about him hence he decides to
share his secret superpower with her at
first tammy doesn't believe a word he is
saying but when nick reads all of her
thoughts she is bound to believe tammy
then tells nick that he is the luckiest
man on earth as he has the ability to
understand women hence instead of
removing it he should take advantage of
the ability nick also agrees to the
concepts and he decides to use it to do
the one thing he loves seduce women
later he approaches lola and again asks
her out on a date this time he finally
convinces her by reading her mind and
telling her everything she desires the
next day at work nick starts getting
along with his female colleagues he
helps them with their work and treats
them with the utmost respect he also
learns that she is secretly working to
secure lotto sports's project and offers
to help as the two continue chatting
darcy finds out that nick has a teen
daughter who happens to dislike him she
then suggests he get new dresses for his
daughter claiming that it is a big deal
for girls when nick returns home he
finds alex discussing an upcoming party
with her two friends he greets her
friends but they despise him for being a
boring dad however he quickly changes
their opinion by offering to take alex
out for shopping this delights the
little girl and she forgives nick for
the earlier incident in the next scene
nick takes lola out on a date and reads
her mind to create the perfect date
after a while he drops a drunk lola near
her home who is desperate to get in bed
with him however since nick wants to
make a long lasting impression on her he
makes up an excuse and leaves promising
to meet soon with days passing by nick
starts spending more time around women
his goal is to understand their psyche
better so that he can become a better
person he also starts spending more time
with darcy and using his special skills
steals her ideas before she can even
mention them although taken aback darcy
decides to remain silent as she believes
that she has started to like him on the
other hand nick's relationship with his
daughter also begins to improve after he
helps her find a prom dress just as
everything is going good nick suffers a
setback he suspects that alex's
boyfriend is only dating her so that he
can make love to her one day he tries to
make her understand that girls should be
wise while choosing their partners but
alex is having none of it instead she
shouts at him that he has no right to
suddenly barge into her life after 15
years and become an overprotective dad
this upsets nick but he knows that she
is correct cut to a week later nick
continues using darcy's feelings for him
to his advantage initially he enjoys the
success that he gets from it but after a
few days he starts feeling bad it turns
out that he too has started liking her
one night he goes over to darcy's place
to design posters for the lotto sports
deal at first they only discuss their
work but soon they start drinking and
having a romantic time they play songs
dance and share their life history with
each other as the two become extremely
drunk they pass out on the floor some
days later lola visits nick outside his
apartment she confronts him for not
contacting her after their last
encounter this time nick feels sad and
to give her a sense of closure he lies
and says that he is gay he also mentions
that if he was straight he would have
married her for sure surprisingly lola
buys the story and hugs him with a sigh
of relief on the day of the lotto sport
presentation nick feels guilty for
stealing darcy's idea so he tells her to
pitch it instead of him however being
the kind woman that she is darcy refuses
claiming that nick came up with the idea
first because of this nick has no choice
but to agree in the next scene nick
again uses his mind-reading skills to
impress the all-female panel at the
presentation as a result his firm
secures the lotto sport contract however
nick is sad about what he's doing to
darcy later he stands next to amir and
practices his speech in which he is
going to reveal everything to her
however just before he can finish darcy
interrupts him and takes him to her
newly bought house there the two have
another romantic date the next day nick
meets his boss dan in his office and
gets some good news and some bad news
the good news is that nick has been
promoted to the position of creative
director the bad news is darcy has been
fired dan mentions that he had made a
huge mistake by hiring darcy as she
didn't utter a single word during the
lot of sport presentation this
devastates nick and he reveals to his
boss that the ad campaign was actually
darcy's idea he also pleads with dan to
hire darcy back soon he decides to go
look for darcy but on the way he gets a
call from his ex-wife gigi who mentions
that alex was extremely upset on the
call for some reason now she has become
unreachable scared nick immediately
heads to alex's party location and finds
her boyfriend with another girl he
confronts the boy about his daughter and
the latter reveals that he dumped alex
because she didn't want to get intimate
this enrages nick and he threatens the
boy before walking off after a bit of
searching he finds alex crying in the
bathroom he then hugs his daughter tight
and the two depart for home following
this he heads to darcy's house and finds
out that she's planning to leave for
another city in an attempt to stop her
he confesses everything he tells her
that he had a supernatural ability with
the help of which he stole her ideas he
also mentions that dan has called her
back to the office when darcy asks him
why he did all of this nick replies that
he was angry and envious at the time as
expected darcy is taken aback and she
berates him for ruining her professional
life she then asks him to leave and
never contact her again at night a
devastated nick wanders around the
streets despite the heavy rain suddenly
he notices hundreds of fish flying as if
they're birds but before he can
comprehend anything he loses
consciousness when he wakes up two women
are staring at him it turns out that he
was struck by lightning nick tries to
hear the women's thoughts but this time
he fails with this he realizes that his
superpowers are finally gone meanwhile
darcy is heading to the airport with her
friend but at the last moment she
changes her mind in the last scene as
nick watches an opera show with his
daughter darcy approaches him and
reveals that she has decided to rejoin
the company and stay with him the movie
ends as nick and darcy start working at
their office together as a couple
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching